[Musique]
hier sur les champs-elysées à minuit
sony mettait en vente les premiers
exemplaires de la nouvelle playstation 3
succès mitigé pour cette opération
marketing il est vrai que le modèle est
cher près de 600 euros la marque vise
désormais un public plus large notamment
les adultes et aussi les seniors jean
françois cyr et samuel mèze eric dasnias
hier soir minuit pile il était l'un des
premiers à craquer pour la playstation 3
sa playstation 3
elle est pour vous la console monsieur
est pas pour aux enfants n'avaient pas
d'enfant c'est moi l'enfant un peu grand
pour jouer aux jeux vidéo
les jeux vidéo pour les grands la
nouvelle tendance aujourd'hui selon
l'agencé française pour le jeu vidéo un
quart des plus de 30 ans y donnent
régulièrement et un joueur sur quatre
est une joueuse les consoles ne sont
plus réservées aux adolescents et ça
sony l'a bien compris ce n'est plus un
loisir pour les enfants que l'on vend à
noël c'est un loisir d'adultes c'est un
phénomène de société qui est en train de
s'installer mais la guerre du jeu vidéo
est impitoyable et les trois concurrents
du marché sans pitié sony et microsoft
parie sur la technologie des consoles
aux graphismes époustouflants qui liste
aussi des cd des dvd bref des machines à
tout faire autre stratégie pour nintendo
dans ses publicités le japonais
s'adresse à tous les publics et
notamment le troisième âge qui se
passionnent pour un jeu un remue
méninges sur console portable la console
et et intelligemment conçu parce qu'en
fait on passe d'un écran à l'autre très
facilement et j'ai trouvé que c'était
très simple c'est très simple à utiliser
votre cerveau à
81,7 des jeux vidéos qu'il ressemble
plus à des jeux vidéo nintendo espère
séduire tous les réfractaires
ceni tanoh pense que
tous les publics sont susceptibles de
s'intéresser aux jeux vidéo aux
conditions on leur offre des thématiques
susceptibles de les intéresser autre
différence le prix la nouvelle sony est
deux fois plus chère que ses
concurrentes 600 euros cette nuit au
pied de la tour eiffel pour un lancement
spécial il s'en est vendu moins d'une
centaine
[Musique]